private housing markets can and should
be the vehicle of choice for helping all
racial and ethnic groups in their quest
for socio-economic upward mobility not
only must the government now foster
integration with also investment and
resource growth in existing black
neighborhoods profit Trump's prejudice
we should stop subsidizing homeowners
with mortgage interest deductions if
their communities fail to embrace the
segregation a private but well policed
housing market is actually the best way
to penalize racism and foster
integration and the best way to enable
all racial and ethnic groups to strive
for financial security and upward
mobility through homeownership
remediation should include a mixed
income public housing program with
apartments affordable to black and white
families of various means I'm confused
as to why Richard having given us this
powerful litany of government created
problems has so much faith in the
government to redress them opportunities
for integration and investments in
existing black neighborhoods are needed
and the private sector is incapable of
fostering either only government can do
so
welcome to this fifth debate of the
third season of the Seoul forum at the
subculture theater in downtown Manhattan
I'm Jean Epstein director of the SOL
forum tonight's resolution reads since
the federal government Foster's housing
segregation in the 20th century the
government should foster housing
integration in the 21st the Columbia
Journalism Review ran a profile of
Jacobin mag editor Bhaskar son Kara
which mentioned me and my soul forum
debate with Bhaskar but said virtually
nothing about the substance of the
debate except that I yelled at Bhaskar
walked the walk and quit talking the
talk the profile was written by Matthew
David Roberts who had attended the
debate so I wrote a letter to the editor
explaining what that I had meant
something quite specific when an urge
Bhaskar to walk the walk and I provided
a link to the podcast into the video of
our debate which is so far gotten over
36,000 YouTube views you might want to
have a look at it if you haven't already
now from the story in Columbia
Journalism Review there was also this
mention before the debate began a
comedian in unzipped in an unzip Twitty
warmed up the crowd with jokes about me
too and Bernie Sanders shortly after an
ill-considered crack but hungry Africans
earned him a few boos from the audience
he said I'm sorry if I stereotyped
Africa he told his hecklers but was not
sorry at all
that was Dave Smith here tonight since
we last saw David our debate in early
December he's become a father to a baby
girl named Leila apparently and
apparently the first half of his podcast
part of the problem is devoted to
accounts of what Leila has recently been
up to but now we want to bring you the
guy in the unzipped hoodie who probably
won't be sorry tonight about offending
us Dave Smith thank you Thank You Jane
hey what's up everybody wow that was
actually that was my favorite intro that
you've ever given me on that they really
the unzipped hoodie part like the jokes
would have been cool if I had just
zipped up the hoodie that is 2019 I'm
being made fun of for dressing like [ __ ]
from communists that's what we're
dealing with now
is terrified get some fashion sense
whatever happened the Communists of
yesteryear who would just always dress
like crap right wasn't that their thing
I don't know that was a great debate
that was a lot of fun my wife will
sometimes still she'll just be walking
around our place and just randomly
she'll just go learn some economics
Bhaskar and we both just laugh and laugh
and laugh I didn't apologize fur
stereotyping Africa what's the point of
Africa if you can't stereotype it I see
I'm sorry I referred to Africa as being
poor you're right they're a very wealthy
continent I never should have done that
it's just nothing but skyscrapers and
mini mansions over there anyway I don't
know I'm I appreciate all of you guys
could come out make it out during this
government shutdown I know it was very
difficult for you to get on with your
life knowing that the TSA agents aren't
being paid this week it's just I wake up
every morning and cry a tear for those
wonderful people like like I can't
believe I might actually make a flight
on time and not get groped today this is
just how are we gonna go on like this
I hate those guys I'm so thrilled
they're not being paid I fly a lot
because I'm a comedian that's like part
of the job and every time they I think
they know on the libertarian like
they [ __ ] with me every single time I
get on the last time I flew they go they
say they go you've been randomly
selected and I'm like yeah sure and they
go you've been randomly selected for
like an extra scrutiny or something I
don't know and then he was like we have
to give you like a full fuller pat-down
than we normally give people and this
TSA agent I'm not making this up this is
real he goes if you feel well if you
feel more comfortable we can do it in a
private room I was like we will do it
right here in front of everybody like
you want to crack a window and light a
candle I want witnesses to whatever's
happening here she was like yeah really
if we could maybe play some Kenny G and
then like get anyway i don't know i'm i
i'm the most unprepared i've ever been
for one of these things i'm exhausted as
gene said i just had a baby she's five
weeks old now oh thank you she's she's
actually a racist so i wouldn't clap
that much for she's uh not a good person
but i told her about the debate and
she's like you ask me we should bring
back segregation and I was like Leila
it's hate fault
but she don't care but anyway it's
really great to have a baby it's amazing
it's challenging I'm very tired if
someone gave me a pillow I could sleep
right here in front of all you people
with no problem that none of the noise
or lights would bother me I would just
it's a it's a trip it's a trip having a
baby they're very demanding and they
they don't do anything they contribute
nothing to society they don't cook or
clean they don't bring any money it you
have to do everything you have to change
them and wipe their ass and then for all
of that they just yell at you when you
do something wrong like they don't even
throw you a thanks pop it's just like
yelling and screaming I don't know it's
a very weird dynamic she I was up till
7:30 in the morning last night just
she's like a terrorist she's such a
terrorist I'm surprised the CIA isn't
sending her weapons like thirds I just
think they could really use her to
overthrow a regime abroad or something
but anyway it's just it's a lot I don't
know but I'm here but here we are at the
debate on you know we're gonna solve all
of
problems of the history of racism in
this country and who better to do it
than a couple of Jews am i right like
who else I don't even mean that
sarcastically if we were gonna solve
racism wouldn't really be a couple of
Jews who would figure this thing out
am i right I know what you're thinking
Dave you're a Jew too but actually since
our last debate I have started
identifying as a Filipino woman so
that's offensive to me I'm also
eighty-six and collecting Social
Security so back off is what I'm trying
thank you one person all right um it's
cool take what you will I don't know the
government imposed segregation so maybe
they should impose integration now I go
further I don't think that's enough I
think we should enslave white people for
200 years just to really even the
playing field up all right and then in
two hundred you in uh in twenty twelve
twenty two nineteen will be like even
freedom let's go you know like what's
really now we're all on the same but
maybe that's not enough I think the
Japanese should get to in turn a bunch
of wasps you know take a bunch of their
property and Jews can kill as many
Germans as they can find just go to town
until you feel even I don't even know
you'll never get enough so it just kill
as many as you want to does that sound
good no
so we not solve the problem I don't know
okay I'm sorry you can't expect these
jokes to be as good with the government
shutdown I get a lot of my inspiration
knowing that the government is fully
functional and open I think these I love
a government shutdown I love it I think
it's like everyone these are the times
when it's best to convince people that
as it turns out we don't need a
government like it's everything's normal
right we could just do this all the time
wouldn't it be awesome I remember saying
this once during the last government
shutdown not the last Trump one the last
one under Obama this is a while ago then
I was like who even cares this is
awesome having the government shutdown
and one woman in the crowd got really
offended much like those commies and she
goes she goes I care that the government
shut down and I was like really
why and she goes I'm a government
employee and I was like oh yeah you're
people who care that is shut down here
the only people that care but I was like
okay fair enough you're a government
employee you don't want it to be shut
down so I was like what do you do for
the government and she said to me so
proud she said I work for the Department
of Wildlife and I was like lady I'm
gonna be honest I didn't even know we
had a Department of Wildlife how many
useless departments are there in this
over bloated government they've got
things I've never even heard of there's
a department of wildlife wildlife the
one area that you would think doesn't
need government intervention at all
wildlife that's what this woman was
throwing at me like you know what the
wildlife is doing right now during the
government shutdown I don't know I'd
assume they're continuing to be wildlife
I don't think they I don't think
somewhere deep in the forest there's
like a bear who's like have you heard
from Susan like we usually usually get
an email around this time I don't even
know what I should be doing today I'm
just gonna sit here until I get some
marching orders cuz you think this is
about that wall Trump is just hilarious
I don't know I don't really care about
the wall I don't really care one way or
the other like I don't think it's an
outrage and I don't really want it I
just I don't really care I think it's
stupid but I think Trump's hilarious I
saw him interviewed earlier today and he
said um we're gonna have a terrific wall
and we already have a lot of terrific
wall and it'll just be terrific and I
was just like I I think I'm sold I don't
know like this I think this guy's just
hypnotized me into his insanity where
I'm like alright I guess it's good like
so I'm just tired I haven't been
sleeping I'm like I think that made
sense to me I don't know someone's
asking me they're like what about the
wall I think it's gonna be terrific I
don't really remember like I can't wait
for the 2020 election I just can't wait
to see him debate more like I love I
love that Elizabeth Warren's running I
hope she wins I think that them debating
would just be amazing how hilarious is
Trump that he just goaded her into that
stupid DNA test and
she just looks like an idiot he tunneled
Trump goes if Elizabeth Warren takes a
DNA test
I'll give her a million dollars and then
she took it and she's like I guess you
owe me a million dollars and then like
reporters asked him they were like so
are you gonna pay her a million dollars
and he was like no and that's just
that's just the end of it like it was
like would you you took that seriously
of course I'm not paying her anything
that's all right
enjoy the debate everybody thank you
very much I appreciate it I'm gonna go
sleep
[Applause]
James Smith I'm a huge fan of his part
of the problem broadcast and you want
more of that listen to part of the
problem podcast is what I should call it
well again the resolution was is since
the federal government for stirred
housing segregation in the twentieth
century the government should foster
housing integration in the 21st taking
the affirmative on the resolution is
Richard Rothstein Richard please come to
the stage taking the negative on the
resolution Howard you suck Howard please
come to the stage Jane please close the
voting and now that the voting is closed
Richard whenever you have a moment
please take the podium and speak for the
affirmative on the resolution take it
away Richard
Thank You Jean
when you invited me for this even-handed
serious debate I had no idea we're going
to open it with an offensive bigger than
so-called comedy presentation and I
would have not have accepted this
invitation had I known that you were
going to do that
well I'm here so I will begin the
serious part of this conversation the
debate premise is that government
fostered segregation in the 20th century
I'll expand it a bit our government and
the word our here is critical not only
Foster's segregation of the racial caste
system that not only segregated
african-americans but the prior them
have equal opportunity they're an income
and acquire wealth to enjoy personal
security and civil rights these
interacted segregation cannot be
remedied in isolation
I'll also reframe the debate challenge
not only must the government now foster
integration with also investment and
resource growth in existing black
neighborhoods because greater racial
equality is a precondition of
opportunities for integration Italians
Jews other ethnics and increasingly
Asians and Hispanics can now choose to
live almost anywhere in metropolitan
areas those who choose to remain
clustered and mostly same ethnic
neighborhoods are not consigned as are
many African Americans to live in
ghettos without access to jobs or
transportation to access those jobs or
under-resourced schools or basic civil
rights such as the right to personal
security without undergoing capricious
arrests or searches opportunities for
integration and investments in existing
black neighborhoods are needed and the
private sector is incapable of fostering
either only government can do so in my
book the color of law I describe many
policies enacted by federal state and
local governments to segregate African
Americans and to press them into a lower
caste without economic or civil
resources the Federal Housing
Administration and veterans in
raishin pursued racially explicit policy
two suburban eyes the urban white
working-class into all white suburbs the
iconic one here in New York Levittown
William Levitt could never have
assembled the capital to build 17,000
homes none Chris old in one place no
bank would lend for such a speculative
activity leather could only proceed by
pledging to the Federal Housing
Administration never to rent or sell to
African Americans the FHA even required
Levitt to place a clause and home deeds
prohibiting resale to African Americans
only then with the FHA guarantee Levites
bank loans this was not the action of
rogue bureaucrats the policy was spelled
out in the FHA manual that bar the
praisers from referring integrated
subdivisions for federal insurance the
manual even ban guarantees for all-white
projects located near black
neighborhoods because they ran a quote
risk of infiltration by in harmonious
racial groups unquote there were
thousands of these developments
nationwide one was Westlake south of San
Francisco described in the song about
little boxes on the hillside made of
ticky tacky in Los Angeles panorama city
Lakewood and Westchester symbolized
suburbanization all had federally
imposed bans on black families homes in
these all-white suburbs were modest
selling for about $100,000 in today's
inflation adjusted money easily
affordable to working-class families of
either race for war veterans down
payments were waived many African
Americans with jobs in the postwar boom
could have afforded these homes more
could have done so if they had not
served and unconstitutionally segregated
armed forces that can sign them to lower
paying roy ranks and jobs and if satan
federal employment agencies had not
honored employer requests to reject
black applicants even more could have
done so afforded to moved to these
suburbs if our government in the 1960s
up until the 1960s had not certified
closed shops and construction unions
that barred black workers from
membership
african-americans were not only
prohibited from living in suburbs they
were prohibited from the lucrative
opportunities to participate in their
construction over the next few
generations as you know working-class
suburban homes appreciated in value they
now sell for three hundred four hundred
five hundred thousand dollars in some
places more white families subsidized by
government to buy into this bargain
market gained wealth from growing
appreciation they used it to send
children to college to subsidize
retirement to weather temporary
unemployment of medical emergencies to
invest in remodeling the further
increased housing value and most
important to bequeath wealth to children
and grandchildren who then had down
payments for their own homes today
suburbs are unaffordable to working in
middle-class families of either race
unless they have downpayment support
from prior generations gifts or requests
average african-american incomes are now
66 o percent of whites but the average
black wealth is only 10% of whites that
enormous disparity between a sixty
percent income ratio and a ten percent
wealth ratio is entirely attributable to
unconstitutional and unremedied federal
policy that we all of us as American
citizens have an obligation to remedy I
mentioned public housing it was not
originally for the poor our first
projects were built as the Great
Depression in the Great Depression by
the New Deal to provide jobs to
construction workers and housing for
working families with stable employment
we did have 25 percent unemployment in
the depression but public housing was
for the employed 75 percent who could
afford housing but who lacked it because
home building was feeble the federal
Public Works Administration and local
agencies used public housing to rigid
rigidify racial segregation will already
existed and to create segregation where
it did not in the mid 20th century many
urban neighborhoods were integrated
because industry and supporting services
located mostly downtown close to river
ports or railroad stations to receive
parts or shipped final products workers
of all ethnicities and both races
Italian Irish Polish Jewish Africa
American didn't have cars to walk to
work so lived in broadly the same
neighborhoods from which they could walk
or take Stuart Street car rides to jobs
the Great America african-american poet
Langston Hughes described growing up in
an integrated downtown Cleveland
neighborhood where his local high school
his best friend was polish and his
girlfriend Jewish the Public Works
Administration demolished integrated
housing there to build separate projects
one for whites one for African Americans
creating segregation there and
reinforcing an elsewhere in Cleveland
with other segregated projects the
pattern was repeated nationally in my
book the color of law I describe some
self-satisfied smug places not just New
York but Cambridge Berkeley and other
places like that
in Cambridge Central Square the area
between Harvard and MIT was integrated
in the 1930s about half black and half
white the Public Works Administration
demolished housing there to build one
project for whites and one for blacks
these and other Boston projects created
segregation that otherwise would never
have developed so rigidly in the West
African Americans were a few prior to
the Second Great Migration of World War
two then a small suburb of Berkeley
Richmond became a great Pacific Ocean
shipbuilding Center drawing 100,000
workers and their families from outside
the region the government built public
housing for these workers for blacks
temporary and shoddy housing along the
railroad tracks and for whites better
housing in white residential areas with
access to shipping to shopping I'm sorry
how did public housing become the slums
that we now associate with it as the FHA
subsidized white suburban moves white
designated public housing emptied out
but there were long waiting lists for
black designated projects soon all were
open to African Americans even the most
bigger than officials couldn't justify
empty projects while others had long
waiting lists public housing became
mostly black and at the same time new
highways laid industry gets parts and
ship products by truck so they no longer
needed to be located in their deepwater
ports and they located the suburbs in
rural area
is good industrial jobs left downtown
black public housing residents became
poorer and their rents had to be
subsidized no longer adequate to cover
apartments for rent with public housing
no longer self-supporting housing
agencies reduced maintenance and
projects deteriorated then in a great
policy misjudgment well-intentioned
housing officials decided that the
poorest applicants needs were so
enormous that middle-class residents
should be evicted to make room for the
poor housing authorities inspected
apartments searching for husbands who's
an income made their families ineligible
to stay thus projects concentrated the
poorest families frequently single
mothers in buildings that were once
mixed income and healthy segregation
that we our government imposed and
reinforced underlies our most serious
social problems today the achievement
gap between black and white school
children reflects the concentration of
disadvantaged minority children into
racially homogeneous schools where their
social and economic problems overwhelm
even the best teachers great health
disparities reflect life and more
polluted neighborhoods and poorly
maintained housing lower black life
expectancy in higher disease rates for
example mass incarceration
disproportionately of young black men
reflects the concentration of the most
hopeless youths in isolated
neighborhoods with little access to jobs
and education I have already mentioned
the enormous wealth gap between blacks
and whites that locks many
african-americans in tune rented
apartments either in the private market
or in public housing located in
under-resourced neighborhoods yet
another result of segregation is our
dangerous political polarization that
closely tracks racial lines and
threatens our very future as a democracy
if so many blacks and whites live so far
apart that we lack any empathy for each
others life experiences how can we ever
create a common national identity my
book the color of law brings together
many public policies that in violation
the fifth fourteenth even the thirteenth
amendments created and reinforced
segregation each of the separate
policies was well known to the public
to scholars and certainly
housing experts like my opponent here
tonight for example the FHA is all white
suburban program was publicized by
Kenneth Jackson's widely read 1985 book
crabgrass frontier with many subsequent
authors recounting the same story yet in
2003 Howard inexplicably described it in
the Manhattan Institute City Journal
like this quote as the US economy boomed
after World War two the lower
middle-class working families for whom
the public housing projects had been
built discovered that they could afford
privately built homes in America's
burgeoning suburbs and by the 1960s they
had completely abandoned public housing
left behind with the poorest most
disorganized non working families almost
all of them hid by single women and he
then went on to explain the
disorganization lack of work ethic and
single motherhood is all that locked and
continues to lock african-americans in
under-resourced ghetto neighborhoods
it's hard for me to understand how
serious attempts to remedy racial
segregation whether public or private
can proceed with such a sanitized
understanding of how we got here but I'm
anxious as you are to hear how Howard
proposes to reverse the disaster for
which previous administrations were
responsible without government remedies
I think that remediation requires
subsidies to African Americans
comparable to the wealth bequests the
descendants of World War two veterans
received and that will enable African
Americans now to buy homes and suburbs
or to purchase an upgrade homes and
existing black communities that they
otherwise would have been able to
purchase fifty and sixty years ago
remediation should include a mixed
income public housing program with
apartments affordable to black and white
families of various means it should
include a ban of land on exclusionary
zoning a ban on exclusionary zoning that
keeps many suburbs overwhelmingly white
it should include inclusionary zoning so
the gentrifying neighborhoods don't
convert from low-income black segregated
places into high income white segregated
places also to ensure that
gentrification does not create reverse
segregation it should include property
tax freeze
for existing homeowners in those
neighborhoods we should stop subsidizing
homeowners with mortgage interest
deductions if their communities fail to
embrace the segregation we should stop
using tax credits and vouchers only to
concentrate low-income minority families
in distressed neighborhoods and instead
use these programs as desegregation
tools we should vastly increase funding
of schools health services and social
workers and low-income neighborhoods
there's much more we could do none of
which is presently on the political
horizon so Howard I hope you can agree
that letting bygones be bygones is not a
constitutionally valid policy if we got
our government out of the way how would
you propose to fix this to desegregate
America
[Applause]
thank you very much Richard thank you
very much
Jean and thank you to the Soho Forum for
inviting me to participate in this
important discussion Richard and I are
going to disagree about a number of
matters this evening but we are not
going to disagree about the history he
recounts the government's role in it and
its enduring impact
I am mystified by one who is so critical
of government having so much faith in
the capacity of government to reverse
the problems that he so brilliantly
describes there is simply no doubt that
starting with Roosevelt's New Deal and
for decades following federal state and
local government actively fostered and
countenanced racial segregation in
housing one reviewer called Richard
story of that history a thorough and
unsettling narrative that brilliantly
corrects the historical record I was
that reviewer so what am I doing here
but in the same review I called the
color in law less successful as a work
of policies prescription I still believe
that as much as it I admire the book
federal housing insurance policies did
beginning with the New Deal infect the
housing market with race-conscious
malware the public housing program which
began in earnest in 1949 under President
Truman segregated blacks from whites
just as it occurred in the Jim Crow
South but we should not proceed because
of that history to believe that nothing
has changed in America since that time
when those government policies weren't
in fact indeed the Harvard economist had
were Glaser and his colleague from the
University of Washington Jacob Victor
have found that based on census data
American cities today are more
integrated than any point since 1910 all
white neighborhoods they write this is
based on census data these are
economists they are not political
advocates all white neighborhoods are
effectively extinct black ghettos
continue they report but they have
declining populations nonetheless there
is no doubt and I agree with Richard
that the residue of government enforced
race segregation is with us ghettos may
be smaller and
population but they persist one can find
large expanses of predominantly black
crime-ridden neighborhoods impoverished
neighborhoods whether in Dallas or
Detroit or Cleveland of Chicago replete
with low value property vacant lots and
few stores it's an enduring irony that
one can generally count on streets named
Martin Luther King Boulevard as being
the main drag of the sort of ghetto
neighborhoods dr. King fought so
strongly against black suburbanization
has reflected the welcome emergence of
an increasing black middle-class but it
is also true as Harvard's David Cutler
has written that in addition to some
self-selection race-related housing
patterns are reinforced by the fact that
as he puts it
White's pay more than blacks to live in
predominantly white neighborhoods that's
because on average they can the question
before us however does not Center on
this past how if at all should new
government efforts seek to ameliorate
the damage of previous ones so in
response to the expanded litany of
government interventions in housing
markets that Richard advocates I'll put
forward different policies that I hope
you'll regard in a similar spirit of
idealism I know that I share that and I
did not enjoy having my viewers
caricature iced as believing that black
people lack a work ethic because I never
wrote that
I'll put forward different policies and
I'll maintain the following as far as
the goal of housing integration is
concerned government can best serve the
interests of all African Americans by
enforcing the Fair Housing Act which
prohibits racial discrimination and
housing otherwise government should let
the private housing market flourish
while also focusing on government's core
roles about which nobody disagrees
including keeping street safe providing
for good schools and the full range of
public goods that make all neighborhoods
good places to live at the same time
local government should and we agree on
this rethink zoning restrictions that
all people that hurt people of limited
means including African Americans but
the idea that the federal government can
waive its magic wand and eliminate all
localism in May
is simply naive if you agree with my
analysis and proposals you'll vote
against the resolution that Richard is
defending for Richard it follows from
the shameful record that federal
government should play an active role in
fostering racial integration in housing
through targeted interventions in the
market this view is misguided in my view
for a number of related reasons it
ignores the surprising damage from such
a government policy including to the
interests of African Americans what's
more it ignores the fact that a private
but well policed housing market is
actually the best way to penalize racism
and foster integration and the best way
to enable all racial and ethnic groups
to strive for financial security and
upward mobility through homeownership
to elaborate permit me to begin with
some aspects of history which Richard
does not emphasize let's travel back by
time machine to st. Louis 1950 before
federal housing programs had been
operating for so long and especially
before the widespread construction of
public housing
it's a city whose housing history I
researched in the context of a review
essay about its infamous project
pruitt-igoe st. Louis in 1950 was the
city of about 850,000 people seven
hundred and two thousand white one
hundred fifty four thousand non-white
who were classified as Negro it was not
a wealthy City median income stood at
$2,700 a year about 28,000 in current
dollars there were to be sure some
predominantly black and predominantly
white neighborhoods but there are some
surprises as well about those
neighborhoods for instance in 98 percent
black census tract on the north side 21
percent of the 36 home homes were the
property that is they were owned by
non-white owners a hundred and seven of
them were multifamily units those are
small businesses you're renting out in
another adjoining process attract ninety
six percent black 23% of all dwelling
units had an owner present before
government intervention these were
neighborhoods in other words in which
African Americans owned property and
were what
in a position to build the wealth we
regret them not building now government
denied them that possibility the census
data includes another surprise nearly 25
percent of st. Louis blacks this was
very much a southern city nonetheless
lived in majority white neighborhoods
private housing markets dispersed
households based on their income and
their ability to pay and that's what was
happening in st. Louis in 1950 as well
as in Langston Hughes neighborhood in
Cleveland which makes me mystified that
you're looking to have the government
come in as the cavalry by the way my
grandmother went to high school with
Langston Hughes in that high school
government she really did government
allegedly representing the interests of
the poor stepped in to interrupt this
process in the North Side neighborhoods
in which blacks had been homeowners
government cleared the site for public
housing creating that black ghetto
called pruitt-igoe residents there could
not by definition become property owners
the st. Louis Housing Authority was the
only possible owner it's not just the
government segregated that was bad
enough government denied anybody in
public housing the right to build wealth
and with rents tied to income the more
you earned the more you paid how'd you
like to have that deal in your apartment
residents lacked the financial incentive
to get out those providing private
low-income housing including many black
property owners were forced to compete
against government subsidized housing
african-americans without doubt face
discriminatory discriminatory public
policies but they also had the
particular misfortune to migrate from
rural areas to urban ones at the same
time as the misbegotten idea of public
housing much have was built long after
Levittown government owned and operated
it reached its zenith even today the
more than 400,000 residents of New York
City public housing the nation's largest
system are denied any means to
accumulate real estate wealth and must
live in degraded conditions to boot why
do we want to trust the government to
fix these problems if it
created these problems in contrast
consider turn-of-the-century 20th
century Harlem were real estate
covenants repeatedly unraveled as
landlords opted to rent to Black's to
maximize their own income these examples
illustrate economist Thomas Souls
principle profit trumps prejudice the
lesson here is this private housing
markets can and should be the vehicle of
choice for helping all racial and ethnic
groups in their quest for socio-economic
upward mobility unlike government
housing problem programs markets make
decisions based on ability to pay branch
rickey figure that out with the Brooklyn
Dodgers others were not willing to use
the talents that were available like
Jackie Robinson he got the drop on them
by realizing that profit trumps
prejudice
the glazier in Victoire findings that
all white neighborhoods have become
virtually extinct shows the virtues of a
private sector-led
approach again this is not to assert
that racially identifiable
african-american ghettos do not persist
northern African American assets when
compared to those of other groups are
not less the question is how to proceed
in light of what we know in ways to
benefit the largest number of people I
am skeptical for several reasons of
Richards well-meaning proposals which he
groups in his book roughly under the
Obama era named affirmatively furthering
fair housing scattering subsidized
housing in what Richard calls higher
opportunity areas more affluent suburbs
brings with it significant complications
in the real world Richard first presents
no evidence that this is a path clearly
preferred by those who would be asked to
play the role of serving as the fair
share residence he cites approvingly for
instance the so-called inclusionary
zoning policy of Montgomery County
Maryland
well I visited that program and I met
residents in that subsidized housing
which stands in the shadows of
McMansions they have these little little
houses there are the big mansions all
around them I met a young woman who
complained well it's pretty good but I
have to make a long bus ride every
Sunday back to the District of Columbia
to attend my church
the New York Times reportedly reported
recently on the increase in
african-american parents in New York
City in Afrocentric charter schools run
in staff mostly by people of color and
which have quote New York Times high
graduation rates and standardized test
scores at or above the city average
we're talking about the racial
achievement gap continues The Times the
debate on how to deal with segregated
City schools is incomplete if it doesn't
take into account what black families
themselves want
we must not discount those their
concerns or the idea that creating a
minority diaspora may even if it has
certain economic benefits would be
targeted on the small number of people
who can receive
at benefits housing clots in Scarsdale
$300,000 to build on those for a unit
how many of those units can we build as
a practical manner there will be many
many people left behind in this
projected policy
moreover let's consider
african-americans who have themselves
because of their work ethic climbed the
housing ladder through employment
through savings these people exist -
let's not think of all black people as
living in ghettos and they've climbed up
the housing ladder from apartment two to
family home two suburban single-family
others who have not made those sorts of
constructive choices will as per
Richards approach in effect receive the
same reward as those who did those
people when I have written about this
subject write me letters saying I don't
want to live next to a housing voucher
household I'm sure sorry that they say
that way but that's how they feel
because they have script and saved in
that context those of us who concerned
about sustainable racial integration
should mine the warning of the Dean of
American sociology Herbert Gans of
Columbia himself a political liberal who
offered the following observation in his
classic book the Levitt owners focused
on the long island community whose early
segregation as part of the story of
Richard tells Sowell rights gans
experience with residential integration
in many communities including Leviton
which is not segregated today indicates
that it can be achieved without problems
when the two races are similar in
socioeconomic level and in the visible
cultural aspects of social class I'm
sorry that people feel that way Richard
but they do moving poor households to
affluent areas because those households
are poor risks being counterproductive
we must keep in mind that those who
believed in public housing
and built more than a million such units
around the country we were all so
confident that their government program
would aid and uplift the poor
what's more inevitably the scattered
sight programs Richard endorses would
serve only that small number of
households land is expensive and
dispersing a handful of households and
costly homes in which median incomes are
high might serve an abstract ideal of
racial integration as a practical matter
it would not do much for most of those
in need
but do these arguments mean that nothing
should be done today to uplift the
african-american poor no but we must in
my view adopt a different approach that
of doing our best to ensure that poor
neighborhoods are also good
neighborhoods where was it written that
that can't be true historically
low-income urban neighborhoods have
served as launching pads for ethnic
groups who went on to become successful
but that is by no means an inevitability
government must invest in what
government should do not intervening in
housing markets in complex ways with
unforeseeable consequences but keeping
neighborhoods safe through effective
policing providing Central's essential
public goods clean parks playgrounds
recreation centers and effective schools
above all segregation all black schools
are always inevitably going to be bad I
just don't know if you're really saying
that but if that's what you're saying it
seems patronizing to me people of good
faith will disagree as to how to provide
good schools charters vouchers or
traditional public schools with strong
parent and teacher associations but they
can be achieved we're seeing that in New
York
that's the revolution of the last 20
years with charter schools everybody can
learn ask Geoffrey Canada at the Harlem
Children's Zone ask Eva Moskowitz at
success academies but safe streets and
good schools are the prerequisite for
upward mobility for the largest number
Boulting a fortunate few to communities
in which
the goods are better is simply not
enough and may be counterproductive
where was it written I repeat that poor
neighborhood can't be good neighborhoods
that they can't be high opportunity
areas nor can we blithely be confident
that what Richard is calling high
opportunity communities will act as such
keep in mind that early public housing
advocates assumed that in a clean
apartment with good lighting not a slum
children would prosper this
environmental determinism proved wrong
good neighborhoods support the
accumulation of skills of social capital
of human capital good life decisions
make for savings and other asset
buildings private markets monitored so
as to eliminate illegal race-based
discrimination reward good life
decisions as reflected in positive
credit scores as those factors work we
will see racial integration were already
seeing it and it will be sustainable
Richard has performed a great service by
telling powerfully the story of malign
government policies but we should not
seek to ameliorate the ill effects
through new ones which poned that pose
their own serious risks thank you
[Applause]
five minutes of rebuttal for you Richard
let me make a few points in response to
Howard's comments first of all these are
in no particular order but things I know
this the Glaser Vig door research the
talks about is quite misleading it
includes all non-whites as contributing
to desegregation the reality is that
african-americans exposure to whites has
improved almost not at all and the data
that they find from increased
integration comes mainly from the fact
that low-income hispanics have moved
into all black neighborhoods and they're
no longer all black many white
neighborhoods now have asians and
middle-class hispanics in them but very
very few african-americans we have not
made the kind of progress in
desegregation that howard implies
secondly the most important point that i
made i hope you will regard that is the
most important is the enormous wealth
gap that these policies created
african-americans I said have ten
percent of the wealth on average that
whites have even though their income
ratio is about 60 percent noting that
Howard described like Attell explained
how we're going to close that wealth gap
simply by the private market economists
say that the intergenerational
correlation of wealth overall for all
families is about point five oh that
means it would take about a generation
to have the wealth gap for the entire
country but Africa the intergenerational
correlation of wealth of African
Americans is much much higher than point
five so it might take 40 percent 40
years rather rather than 20 even to have
the wealth gap with no further
government policy but if we're opposed
to government policy most of the
government policy that we now employ
truly reduces the intergenerational
wealth gap for african-american Social
Security minimum-wage policies that
various social safety net policies that
contribute to african-american income
and that shorten the time it would take
to narrow the wealth gap if we
eliminated those as well or narrowed
them or fail to support them and enhance
them the gap would go would extend even
longer children prospered in public
housing before white families white
working-class families were subsidized
to leave public housing along with the
jobs that supported both black and white
families into suburban and rural areas
what was left was neighborhoods of
concentrated disadvantage with you a few
jobs available few good jobs available
that could support families I mentioned
one the the the the actions of not only
public housing authorities but welfare
officials to remove husbands from public
housing units contributing to the single
family a single-parent family its
intensity that exists in
african-american communities although as
we all know I hope the single parenthood
is increasing among whites much more
rapidly today there is among African
Americans the African American single
family single parenthood is not
increasing whites are increasing at a
phenomenal rate
we are having both a cultural phenomenon
and an economic one of the problem is
that we cannot reverse biology but we
can provide some families middle class
white families in particular with the
economic resources to support families
it's a support children without a
two-parent household african-american
families without access to those jobs
don't section 8 housing by the way is
primarily not a program for single
mothers with children it's primarily a
program for disabled and senior citizens
but of those African Americans who do
have
Section eight vouchers with families
they're almost all working most of them
are working about 10% are involved in
the temporary assistance from need of
families and while not working they are
in job training programs or in
educational institutions these are not
unmotivated people I guess a profit
trumps prejudice okay I guess I'm out of
time but well profit crunched Reza
it'sit's not the case that profit trumps
prejudice up in 1960 the chairman of the
Federal Reserve Board was asked how come
he didn't do anything to prevent banks
from discriminating against African
Americans in the way in which they
issued mortgages since the Federal
Reserve was inspecting and very
rigorously inspecting banks he said well
if any bank refused to lend to African
Americans others would seize the
opportunities and lend to them instead
even though he well knew that every
single bank in the country was refusing
to lend to African Americans for housing
thank you
it's worth keeping in mind that profit
will not trump prejudice in a completely
unpolished environment if everybody is
allowed to discriminate they will seek
profit by doing so but the Fair Housing
Act was passed in 1968 not in 1960 so we
have a changed legal environment since
the time that that occurred if we're
talking about how to build wealth and I
think that is a key thing to worry about
how do we close that wealth gap I do not
believe it will happen by building
subsidized public housing in the
scarsdale's and and where does Trump
live in New Jersey whatever where he
lives bed yeah bed mr. tempting as that
might be right that is not going to
solve the problem because these are
subsidized rental units this has been
the recipe for ongoing serfdom for poor
people to be in these rental units
subsidized they have such a good deal
they don't want to leave the more income
they make the higher their rent goes
that's the rules of this program and I'm
really confused about why public housing
was so good in the early days when there
were all black and all white projects if
it was so good for white people and
their children prospered why didn't
black people's children prosper because
they were denied the possibility of
upward mobility because they could never
own property was the FHA wrong to
discriminate yes but public housing was
just as wrong to and we should not
repeat that mistake which Richard is
inexplicably urging us to do
inexplicably zoning is a really
interesting issue and he mentioned that
before let me elaborate on that we're
starting to see local zoning come apart
at the seams and it's a really welcome
development it's going to be good for
all people of modest means in
Minneapolis there's a move to densify
the single-family suburbs to allow the
construction not of high-rise public
housing projects which are going to
guarantee a
anteed to foment the most opposition but
if two family three family small
apartment buildings on corners even that
is going to be hard for them to sell the
City Council there is finding but we're
starting to see the iron wall of local
exclusionary zoning crack under economic
pressure because people can't have a
place for their kids to move into we're
starting to see private economic forces
undermine exclusionary zoning the idea
that the federal government will deny
Community Development funds or mortgage
subsidies to communities that are said
to discriminate you want to create a
firestorm that will create a firestorm
if you let local government say wait a
minute this is not working we've got to
change it Seattle's considered the same
thing San Jose is considering the same
thing I call it densification gradually
exclusionary zoning will wither away
from economic forces in the private
market if we have heavy-handed
government intervention we will have
controversy it may feel good for the
virtuous signalers but it will not get
the job done as far as section 8 goes 38
roughly a third elderly or third
disabled and a third single parents not
all black of course but it is a program
in which single parents dominate I'm not
sure why we're talking about that
exactly but thanks a lot
[Applause]
we're gonna go now to the QA portion of
the evening thank you both for your
eloquent and impassioned presentations I
want to start with by exercising
moderators prerogative to ask a couple
of questions I'm Howard I believe that
Richard said that he does indeed as you
agreed once to rollback the zoning laws
the zoning restrictions that make it
difficult for people to produce
high-rises for poor people
I think Richard also said that he wants
to rollback or perhaps abolish Richard
is that the mortgage interest deduction
did I have you right you spoke about
that I thought no mortgage interest
deduction
I thought you want to roll that back
it's a substantive why people in the
suburbs or even Mike please Mike Mike I
said the mortgage interest deduction can
be used as leverage to encourage
suburban communities to desegregate the
specific proposal I have is that the
mortgage deduction should be withheld
from families and suburbs that for
example maintain exclusionary zoning
among other policies that discriminate
okay but that the interest deduction
should be placed in escrow and return to
those families at the point where their
communities take steps to desegregate
okay you clarified that so that was my
question for Howard and do you do you
support that idea yeah I find that to be
breathtaking so here I am I'm a regular
guy in Levittown and I didn't vote for
this discrimination I had nothing to do
it that I moved in here and you're
telling me I'm not going to get this
deduction because of something that
happened before I even moved into this
community you're going to tell this
community how it should vote now maybe
in an ideal world that would make for
something better
I can guarantee you you would set off a
political firestorm of incredible
proportions please keep the mic near you
right and so let's be practical let's be
practical
let's have HUD propose model zoning
codes
have the HUD secretary go around and
promote those models owning codes let's
encourage communities because they're
starting to understand this already
because of private economic pressure but
that kind of heavy-handed intervention
denies the local tradition in America
and is going to just create so much
controversy you're never gonna get to
where you want to go oh well I said
explicitly that the policies on
proposing I described before not
politically realistic in today's
environment of course they would create
the buyers look excuse me let me finish
of course they would create a firestorm
so did school desegregation in 1954
create a firestorm
none of this change is easy but once a
political consensus evolves they will
become easier they will never be easy
yeah okay and then now you may be able
to respond later Richard my question for
you and you should probably keep the mic
in your hand if it's good and then if
you could if you could but don't have to
necessarily but but anyway okay question
for you Richard you you sort of
surprised me as a listener when you said
well you said I hope you got my central
point it's all about the wealth
disparity you said 60% for blacks in
terms of income and only 10% in terms of
wealth it's all about the wealth
disparity so if you see my question in
my mind then is as how it suggested
putting people in public housing with an
only thing is not a good solution but
then more precisely if the wealth
disparity is the issue why not just have
a cash transfer of wealth to blacks and
then for example if they want some
wealth they don't necessarily have to
buy a home if they just buy some stocks
and bonds I don't know anything any real
estate not any I just have stocks and
bonds so that's my wealth so give them
more options just make it cash as
fungible if wealth is your concern why
not just have a referendum that says all
whites have got to hand all non-blacks
have got to handle over a certain number
some money to all blacks that's the
central concern let's do that why not
well I don't think you heard what I said
there okay what I said before I did not
say that the way to solve the wealth gap
was to put section 8 vouchers or
subsidized housing into suburban
communities what I said was one policy
we could do to redress the wealth gap is
to subsidize the purchase of homes for
African American Americans in suburban
communities that today unaffordable to
them the same kind of subsidy that the
federal government gave to white
families that enable them to move into
those suburbs 50 and 60 years ago but
deny to African Americans we didn't
create the wealth gap by handing out
cash to white families the wealth gap by
subsidizing their purchase of homes and
appreciating communities well that's
going to be the same thing today
well yes but my bank just let me give
you the question that that's one way but
but if you if your central concern is
the wealth gap then isn't it most
directly addressed wealth because wealth
is not just housing lots of people are
rich in stocks and bonds and maybe they
ran who could whatever what of it
they may have a few million in stocks
and bonds or something else so why not
just have a cash transfer well are you
opposed to that why not isn't doesn't
that more directly address the wealth
gap gives everybody options well if the
wealth gap is not the only problem I
says what's the chief problem I think
you know if you want to give cash
transfer so you talk about the political
firestorm that surpass anything I ever
proposed not because I'm trying to I
tried to set forth a menu of policies
all of which would contribute to
narrowing the gaps that we have and the
segregation that we have one of them
would be to do a comparable thing for
African Americans to what we did for
whites and that is to subsidize their
purchase of homes in communities that
today are unaffordable to them but that
would have been off for the bill to them
had they prepared to buy into it when
whites did okay that's that's the end of
my questions well I do like do you
either you at this point have questions
for the other or should we give it over
the audience no no okay audience
questions
we're lined up and please rephrase your
question as a question you don't have to
identify who you are unless you feel
it's directly relevant to the question
long statement first no okay
short-shorts ad okay so question it's
actually gene anticipated my question
which is if the debate tonight is a
debate between a compensatory view from
Richard and a view that that's a
terrible idea
and didn't work before or not gonna work
this time if we just had a choice
between two forms of compensation which
is genes question but I'd love to hear
from Howard and Richard if it was okay
same-same present value you know some
whatever Larry Summers thinks is the
same present value you're either gonna
have reparations and a settlement for
all the bad stuff the American
government did to black people over the
last whole existence or you're gonna
have an ongoing God knows we're gonna
end the program subsidy program that's
gonna distort the market and do other
stuff but it's gonna be you know
Elizabeth Warren wants 40 billion
dollars a year of affordable housing if
the debate tonight was between we have a
choice we need to do compensation that's
premise of the debate but it's either
we're gonna do reparations or we are
going to have a targeted really smart
blue ribbon panel housing program that
will review every decade to see if we've
gotten there yet what what do you both
pick between those two because I I'm
surprised if we can't form some like we
can't even get there on that we have to
do them so a cash transfer or it's your
question but a slightly different it's
if the debate was we're doing
compensation
it's either reparations or it's a you
know decade review housing targeted blue
ribbon panel forever subsidy by
Reformation you mean cash transfer okay
how would you go first because Richard
already incident what's your answer
Helen well my answer is that he just
proposed a different debate okay okay
yeah all right right I wasn't prepared
for that debate but I will say this I
just don't think either of those as a
practical solution I'm sorry it's a
cop-out but I'm not gonna buy into
either of those I will point out in
terms of the distortions of compensation
and credit support one of them causes
there are multiple causes the private
sector did some crazy stuff in the 2008
financial crisis but one of the problems
was government insured allocation of
capital to families that were
disadvantaged by virtue of their
zip codes and their minority status in
the real world again that resulted in
incredibly high default rates because of
poor underwriting standards because
banks wanted to meet their quotas under
the Community Reinvestment Act this was
a disservice to the people in whose name
it was authored so if I had to choose I
you know if there were a reparations
program that how do you decide who gets
that money you don't have to choose okay
Richard Rick did you wanna make a
comment good yeah I agree with with
Howard about this the choice is a silly
one this is a complex problem and it
can't be solved with one or the other
solution but so far as the the Community
Reinvestment Act this is a conservative
trope that has been widely discredited
most of the the subprime lending that
was exploitative that was targeted to
african-americans with terms that were
not that were far worse than the terms
that were offered to whites that
resulted in exploding interest rates and
and the defaults were not issued by
banks that were regulated by the
Community Reinvestment Act they were
issued by private mortgage brokers
private mortgage companies which are not
covered by the Act it did not require
government quotas to get the private
sector to exploit african-americans with
the subprime lending okay I'm gonna
rebut because I beg to differ there was
an element of of people who took
advantage of the spigot from Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac which are government
entities have made credit available
willy-nilly and no bank will tell you
that they are not desperate to meet
their community reinvestment standards
by initiating loans not necessarily
having those loans be repaid that is a
disservice I I did journalism on this on
the south side of Chicago and I talked
to homeowners who had the abandoned
house next door to them their wealth was
no longer being increased and it was
because of government
mention in the market not despite it
that question Thanks next question hi
yes thank you this question is gonna be
a rule I guess New York focused we're a
large city focused and there's a second
part spirit need for a hot second first
what sort of a approach do you think is
appropriate with respect to ameliorating
housing issues by up zoning by moving
policy around building to something like
as of right / like what is allowed in
zoning or I guess streamlining is
processes or things like that to make it
easier to build more housing in more
places in cities like New York or San
Francisco or whatever housing is very
expensive I guess the second part of my
question is how can either do you really
justify any sort of policy proposal that
incorporates mortgage interest loan
deductions when that's effectively just
a wealth transfer from working young
renters like myself and many other
people here tonight to find gentlemen of
distinguished age and accomplishment
like yourselves yeah I'm not so Richard
one second at first maybe take the
second question first the second part of
the question because you know he's a
fronted you directly going on I couldn't
agree with questioner more I'm
absolutely happy to give up my mortgage
interest deduction I think it is
unconscionable it's a distortion in the
market when when NPR host say to me well
how can you be opposed to public housing
when you're in favor of mortgaging I'm
not in favor of mortgage interest
deduction so it's a SAAP to the
homeowners home builders lobby that's
what it is and you it is an
intergenerational theft of wealth so I
don't rich
however needs it to use as a hammer in
his policy so keep that in mind when you
vote well I just want I just want to I
just want to record for the record that
the way to not take your mortgage
interest deduction Howard is not to take
it so on what I'm gonna make a
charitable contribution to Governor
Cuomo instead make the contribution to
the sella form we can use the money well
yeah I agree with Howard I in principle
I think the mortgage interest deduction
is completely unjustifiable but it's
there and I would like to use what's
there as what leverage we can to try to
desegregate this country it's an
important tool that we could use there's
something about the mortgage deduction I
think that we ought to call out and that
is the mortgage interest deduction is an
entitlement any whether they follow
genes advice or night or not any
homeowner who meets the requirements of
the mortgage interest deduction is
eligible to take it that's what we do
for homeowners what we do for renters is
have a program that is an appropriation
restricted it's not an entitlement those
people who get subsidies for for low
income renting aren't entitled to it
just because they meet the requirements
the government appropriates a certain
amount of money when the money runs out
you don't get it so about 1/3 of the
eligible families who are on waiting
lists for example for section 8 vouchers
are the only ones who get that mortgage
interest deduction anybody who wants it
can get it
I agree with that okay and too much news
you're gonna create a new waiting list
by the way if you start to build a
limited number of subsidized apartments
if you think one-third is small number
for vouchers but this just in in the
because of the tax reform Act about 8%
of Americans are going to itemize their
deductions that means they're not going
to itemize the mortgage interest
deduction anymore they're going to take
a standard deduction and that's
available to everybody in the country
who pays income taxes so we've just had
an important change interesting next
question please
a chance yes excuse me
she's mean if you have a question you
have to be up at the mic what the zone
I'm saying oh there's only okay oh sorry
I what about what about the zoning that
was the first part of the question that
was two questions but you know that's a
little bit much but okay you wonder if
you've shot it out it's a raucous crowd
you know you want to comment on the
zoning well yes we have lots of problems
in this country racial segregation is
not the only one as I think you see you
implied there are young white people who
can't afford housing either because of
the housing shortage that we have and
one of the things that perpetuates that
housing shortage is zoning that needs to
be up zoned that we need to stop
restricting exclusionary zoning was
established as I keep document in my
book as a way of getting around a
prohibition on explicitly racial zoning
it reinforces it establishes it
perpetuates exclusivity racial
exclusivity that was created by the FHA
it should be abolished but the only
reason to abolish it is not just for
racial reasons it's because we have a
housing crisis of the effects of young
people that affects professionals we are
not building a sufficient amount of
housing to house people of both races
and of all income levels yeah a few a
few points about that first of all
zoning is actually a residue from the
Progressive Era it was not invented to
racially exclude although it's been used
to that effect progressives believed
that industrial uses commercial uses and
residential you should should be
separated in a beautiful city and in
1924 the Supreme Court in its wisdom and
Euclid V Ambler agreed with the
progressives and Zoning spread like
wildfire all across the country of
course it suppresses building compared
to as of right the danger we have first
of all the danger we have in New York is
that zoning by permission of the mayor
that is will relax the zoning if you do
this
this and this for us that creates a new
world of complications for instance in
Brooklyn in a in a Crown Heights area
which is bordered by minority
communities poor black people and
Orthodox Jews there's a project going up
and the project gives gives priority to
community residents in the Orthodox
Jewish neighborhood because that's where
that project is located zoning is still
being used to racially exclude because
it's at the sufferance of the government
if there were a general deregulation and
as of right zoning were more than norm
you wouldn't have government trying to
pull the strings that way in which the
zoning the the up zoning is limited and
conditional and by the way there's not a
housing crisis accepted San Francisco
Boston New York and Washington there's
no housing crisis in Buffalo I'm from
Cleveland believe me there's no housing
crisis you can sell your parking space
in New York and buy 3 mansions at Shaker
Heights I'm not kidding I saw my parking
space for a lot of money you're right
just just one one short well I think is
a correction Howard is right that's
owning two separate industrial and
commercial uses from residential uses
was a progressive idea but the idea of
separating single-family zoning from
multifamily zoning came about after 1917
when the Supreme Court said you couldn't
do racial zoning Secretary of Commerce
Herbert Hoover convened the Commission
to figure out the way around that that
prohibition and the separation of single
family from multi-unit zoning was
developed as a way of perpetuating
racial segregation next question hi good
evening
so I heard tonight that there are about
a million units of
housing public housing built all across
the country and mostly lived in by black
people and no no that's not true no
maybe a forty percent maybe forty
percent okay there are there are many
predominantly black public housing
problems what is it about 18% of the
population of black and forty percent in
housing so great disproportionate is
your point yeah yeah yeah okay well so
it seems that one of the easiest ways to
solve this problem is to give the unit's
to the people who currently live in them
thereby you've transferred some wealth
and I don't know they're they're not you
know subject to the raising the rents
and based on their income etc what do
you think about that idea yeah that'd
give you giving it's in public housing
as a you know they only make it condos
they own the apartments your reaction
Richard yeah well as I said public
housing began as a middle-class program
it was the most desirable housing
available it wasn't the disadvantageous
children flourished of both races both
blacks and whites flourished in public
housing the reason that
african-americans change their
allegiance from Republican to Democrat
during the New Deal is because they got
some housing which was highly desirable
it was segregated that was a negative
aspect of it but it was better than
nothing they were living in many of them
were living in deteriorated slum
conditions and public housing was a
benefit could you jazz the question but
public housing deteriorated because
middle-class families were evicted from
it both by subsidies as I described by
the Federal Housing Administration and
then by regulations to provide housing
for the poor and prohibit middle-class
families from taking up spaces that
could be occupied by the poor once
public housing consists only of the most
disadvantaged families it can't be a
healthy place to live people's
disadvantages reinforce each other when
public housing was mixed income when it
had middle-class families in it they
were healthy places to live and if we
created mixed income public housing
again today as one of the ways to solve
the housing crisis not just
racial crimes in crisis but the housing
crisis that affects all families today
that would begin to start us on the
right direction
but you know just lose your answers no
to the highest chance just yeah that's
right my answer is no just want to make
it clear how it go ahead no yes or no
okay I call people bring that up all the
time your conservator you must want to
sell these units to to the people of
their no I call that lemon capitalism
lemon socialism is when the the
Pennsylvania Railroad goes bankrupt and
the government bails it out and creates
Amtrak that's called lemon socialism it
was a lemon the government bought it
this is lemon capitalism we let we let
these units deteriorate to the point
where they're the worst slums in New
York and then wait we're gonna give them
to you this is great huh why would that
be a good idea I'll tell you what I
would be in favor of however which is
buy people out by people out you live
here 20 years we'll give you $10,000 for
every year you live there will empty out
the building will sell the land to a
private developer and we'll get the city
out of the public housing business once
and for all that's what I would be for
okay next question hi thank you so much
for coming this question is for dr.
Rothstein although either you feel feel
free to weigh in Martin Luther King said
and I quote many of us Negroes live
above our means spend money on non
essentials and frivolities and fail to
give to serious causes and organizations
a Malcolm X said and I quote the black
man here man for man is forever the
biggest consumer at the same time that
he's the biggest non producer in 2016
the market research firm Nielsen found
that black Americans despite having less
wealth and whites are more likely to buy
a luxury car and more likely to buy
jewelry in any given year so in reducing
the wealth gap which you say is your
chief concern do you see any role for
discussing spending patterns in the
black community
I just tell you right now I'm not gonna
touch that question what it wasn't meant
for you anyway it's meant for nobody
asked you know we can use a little bit
more virtue in all communities in this
country I don't think that them focusing
on african-americans is the way to begin
and now it reduces to to answer yeah
Frank that wouldn't dignify it with a
response to have to plate with that kind
of broad brush it's ridiculous next
question so you've mentioned that the
pernicious effect of government programs
on housing which is plausible and I
think fairly well documented
I guess what's surprising is the level
of harm which you're laying out that
public housing has affected minority
populations whether or not they were in
communities that were in public housing
that it's responsible for the wealth gap
that that essentially we screwed it all
up by letting white working-class people
move to the suburbs have it would seem
that there's a lot of natural tests
there where we could prove some of those
points or identify the level of harm
have you looked at it as as part of your
studies well I I didn't say we let white
families move to the suburbs we
subsidize them to do so an explicitly
racial basis and the suburbs couldn't
have been created without government as
I said as I described Leavitt could
never have built Levittown without
government's of financing no bank would
be crazy enough to lend them the money
to build 17,000 homes in one place the
only way you could do it was a
government insured bank loan to do it so
we even just led Africa let let I'm
sorry let White's move to the suburbs we
subsidize them to do them too so we
created an apartheid system of housing
with explicit government policy you know
you said before that no bank would ever
have bankrolled Levitt
to me love it has taken advantage of a
program that's there you know do we know
that absent the government program
he wouldn't have taken more risk put
more of his own money in it
I'm just perplexing that there's always
a drumbeat markets fail markets fail
markets won't support the banks markets
won't invest in poor communities
government has to twist the markets arm
I'm just not convinced by that do I
believe that what you said happened and
that he took advantage of the FA FHA
yeah you know just like Donald Trump's
father took advantage of rent
stabilization in New York anybody that
needs an apartment in New York be crazy
not to get a rent stabilized apartment
even though it's a distorting and
counterproductive policy would there
never have been investment without that
would people of means not chosen to move
to the suburbs versus living in a
government operated project you've been
to the projects lately you know they
have they have fences around all the the
lawns it's like you're in a prison right
you can't even you don't mow the lawn
the government does that for you you
want to have a garden no you can't do
that it's institutionalized living they
didn't need a subsidy to want to get out
of there anybody would want to get out
of there well that wasn't the condition
of public housing when the government
created this subsidy as I said this was
the most desirable housing available for
working-class families of either race
and only White's were permitted to to do
it but we know do know that Levitt would
not have been able to do it without the
government prior to the FHA there was no
such thing as single-family homes for
middle-class families the only people
who could buy single-family homes with
the affluent because there was no such
thing as an amortized 20 or 30-year
mortgage before the FHA came in and
created it the only mortgages that were
available were short-term five years
sometimes seven years with a balloon
payment interest only and no
middle-class working-class family could
ever afford to buy a home on that basis
the only way that Levitt or any of these
other developers could build these
subdivisions was with FHA support for
the bank loans combined with a an
amortized mortgage of 20 or 30 years
that permitted for the first-time
middle-class and working-class families
if they were white
to buy single-family homes yeah but that
ignores the fact that we had a banking
market distorted by regulation banks
could not branch across state lines
commercial banks and savings and loans
had distinct markets regulated by the
government
we we didn't have who's the guy that
advertises on late-night TV to give you
a mortgage the guy from Detroit who my
thinking turned out ok anyhow we now
know because that market has been
deregulated private credit is flowing
the bank market of 1954 when William
Levitt was building was idea was us was
a constrained market constrained by
government regulation so was that a good
thing no was the FHA doing a good thing
no but let's not mistake that for
believing that private markets will not
serve the interests of the housing
market that was the assumption of
Katherine Bower in her landmark book
modern housing in 1936 she went to work
for the Roosevelt administration after
writing the book she believed that the
private housing market would by its very
nature fail two-thirds of the population
it hasn't worked out that way a final
question I believe we have under time
but one more question so you're the
person soccer - thank you thank you
I like there - a question you mentioned
the term scattered site housing I wonder
if you know that what that means going
up New York in the 1970s it reminds us
of Forest Hills housing it reminds us of
just north of New York City Yonkers what
do your parents be different than that
or what I went for both you to answer
thank you did you understand the
question yeah there have been a number
of experiments or not experiments number
of efforts to create scatter site
housing they've mostly been successful
I'm not most of them are not high-rises
they're low-rise units gathered
throughout communities where they're
permitted where there's not zoning
restrictions on them
and they've been successful yeah well I
would differ in the policy because I
wouldn't do it so that would be a
difference but as far as them being
successful I believe you could probably
sneak a few of these developments in
with limited resistance but and this was
my core point how do you serve the best
way the most people it's not a few units
for a fortunate few it's serving the
interests of the majority of poor people
in this country black and white by
government doing its job to keep the
streets safe to keep the schools good to
keep the parks clean and scattered site
housing is kind of beside the point
that'll have to be a final question
thanks guys
so we now go to the final part of the
evening summary statements five minutes
apiece take it away Richard well thank
you very much I'm going to use this time
to try to sum up my approach without
dealing directly with the points that
Howard is raised some people have
criticized the approach I've described
they say that private discrimination not
government was the chief cause of racial
segregation residential segregation they
say was well established before
government got involved during the New
Deal and if so then residential
segregation is de-facto
the common term one we all use not a
government-sponsored system and the
facto segregation does not make
government remedies obligatory indeed
current Supreme Court doctrine says that
racially explicit policies are
prohibited to remedy de facto
segregation of course private
discrimination play the central role in
government at all levels was responding
to the demands of many probably most
white voters who insisted that
discrimination be incorporated into
government policy but an
unconstitutional system does not require
that government was the only actor
indeed the bill of right
and the Civil Rights amendments exist
only to establish a requirement that
government refused to cave to private
prejudice and private demands that
government violate civil rights if for
example local ordinances in the South
had not required segregation of
restaurants private establishments would
have refused to serve black customers on
their own but when government endorsed
the private bigotry with ordinances it
became an unconstitutional system that
we were obligated to reform even though
private bigotry demanded it for housing
the case is even clearer as I said a few
minutes ago William Levitt would have
refused well he didn't say it I'll say
it now William Levitt would have refused
to build homes for african-americans on
his own even if government hadn't
required that he was a bigot he wrote
that he was refused to sell homes
african-americans even if government
hadn't required it but when government
required him to do so it became a Fifth
Amendment violation that we are required
unless we want to abolish the entire
constitutional framework under which we
live that were required to take steps to
remediate notwithstanding with Howard is
written when White's did not suddenly
discover suburban opportunities and then
leap at the chance to leave they're less
motivated black countrymen behind
that's not how racial segregation was
created if it is required to do the FHA
had conditioned Levites and other
developers bank guarantees on a
non-discrimination policy our nation's
racial landscape would look a lot
different than it does today
perhaps some bigger than white families
were refused to move into homes that
were integrated but the housing shortage
was so great as it is today that for
every family who refused their word many
would have been many wanting to take its
place the failure to act of the FHA to
act in accordance with its
constitutional responsibilities is one
of the great tragedies of the 20th
century it would have been so relatively
easy for us to have a different outcome
a different racial landscape today I
sometimes face questioners to say my
grandparents as Howard said weren't even
in this country when these policies you
describe or
since they came here my family has
worked hard to get where we are today
we're not responsible for these policies
why should we now have to sacrifice for
example with higher taxes or the removal
of the mortgage interest deduction to
fix it I answer this in two ways first
hardwork alone could not have created a
more advantaged white middle class at
the government subsidy to create it we
would not have middle-class suburban
subsidies today were it not for the FHA
as I mentioned a few minutes ago were it
not for the FHA we would not have 20 and
30-year amortized mortgages and homes
would have been unaffordable to
middle-class families it's only because
of the FHA and lay their Freddie Mac and
Fannie Mae that we have that system
secondly every American enjoys the
privileges of living in this democracy
every one of us does even if our
forebears weren't here to fight to win
our liberties in the Revolutionary War
and then many other struggles since but
in addition to enjoying privileges of
citizenship that our own particular
ancestors had no role in creating
American citizens also chair in the
obligation to enforce our Constitution
including making sacrifices to remedy
violations of civil rights that our own
ancestors had no responsibility in
committing and so I hope all of you will
join me in accepting this responsibility
to remedy such violations a
responsibility there's a necessary
complement to the privileges that we
enjoy thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks Richards and thanks for agreeing
to participate in this debate I said in
my prepared remarks that I offered my
comments and I hope they would be taken
in the same spirit of idealism that
richard has offered his ideas and I do
offer them in a spirit of idealism as
somebody who came of age in the 1960s
this issue of segregation has been in my
life in the public life in which I've
lived that entire time and it's terribly
disappointing to see it remain so toxic
and so with us and so for me to be
characterized as saying I believe that
black people are less motivated than
white people I don't know where that
came from and I resent it to say that I
said that my grandparents worked hard I
didn't say that I was talking about
taxpayers in Levittown I understand that
it's easier to address a caricature of a
conservative rather than this actual
person who was here but I'm not that
person
the person that I am and the and the
position I'm arguing for is is one of
concern for the aspirations of all
Americans and doing what we can to put
those aspirations forward Nathan glaze
of the great sociologist at Harvard went
back and forth back and forth on
affirmative action first he was against
it then he was for tortured by it it is
a torturous issue all these issues are
torturous finally he came around
recently to saying I just don't know
what to do but to proceed as if African
Americans are minority like all other
minorities because I don't know what
else to do
we have to help make poor neighborhoods
good neighborhoods we have to help make
all schools good that will in time is it
fair that the wealth gap exists no it's
not fair we simply can't wave a magic
wand and make it disappear no set of
policies will make it disappear quickly
there aren't enough houses we can build
that will close that wealth gap we have
to and it was Lyndon Johnson who created
headstart with that in mind it was
compensatory that's still a good idea
even though head starts not as
successful as it should be that's where
we have to put our resources our limited
resources have to go in making all
neighborhoods good neighborhoods to
uplift all to give them the options when
you look at West Chester County which is
under court order because of being said
not to have done enough to promote
housing integrations kind of ground zero
for the policies Richard is talking
about if you look at the dispersion of
families based on income so their median
income in Scarsdale is about $250,000 a
year about two percent of
african-american households in
Westchester County earned $250,000 a
year two percent of Scarsdale families
are african-american that's the criteria
we should use if people who are roughly
in line with the income levels in the
neighborhoods in which they want to live
they should absolutely have the full
force of the government to make sure
they are not turned away from any house
they can afford to buy or rent but as
soon as we start putting our finger on
the scale we are going to create more
problems that we solve fundamentally I'm
confused as to why Richard having given
us this powerful litany of government
created problems has so much faith in
the government to redress them
I don't have that faith although I
deeply share his concern thank you so
much
[Applause]
well thank you both for very impassioned
very eloquent class reviews again
the resolution again specifically is
since the federal government fostered
housing segregation of the 20th century
the government should foster housing
integration in the 21st or is the vote
voting over okay yeah okay
the those in favor of the resolution
were initially 27.8% you those in favor
of the resolution ended up being 29% and
change so the yes votes picked up one
poor 1.4 percent of the vote that's the
number to beat the no vote went from 52%
to 66% picking up nearly 14% so the
Tootsie Roll goes to the no vote
congratulations to you both and also
thank you very much and also Richard
Richard Rothstein will be selling the
book that how in her sac thinks is a
must read that's the one issue they both
agree about for 20 bucks and guys we
have to come off the stage quickly
before the groupies enter the stage so
thanks very much
[Music]